it takes a long time to make a movie
even if a production does completely
stay on schedule so if a scene proves to
be more complicated than others things
can get out of control relatively
quickly every now and again you'll hear
of massive delays and setbacks that
emerge mid chute whether it's due to
onset injuries or a centerpiece action
scene eating up huge amounts of extra
time or perhaps a demanding director who
just wants several dozen takes to have
some choices in the editing room
unforeseen circumstances surrounding a
scene can make a movies production
process go right off the rails here are
some movie scenes that ended up being
unexpectedly massive undertakings for
the cast and crew spidey-senses before
there was the marvel cinematic universe
Peter Parker swung on two screens in
director Sam Raimi's 2002 blockbuster
spider-man the film helped usher in the
new superhero movie Renaissance since
Hollywood was still trying to figure out
what comic-book movie audiences really
wanted to see
similarly influx was the state of
special-effects though the digital
revolution rolled out through the 90s
CGI was still undergoing the occasional
growing pains at the turn of the
millennium
many of Spidey stunts would be achieved
digitally but they don't exactly hold up
when compared to what the webhead gets
up to in his newer adventures Raimi has
often spun his fascination with sleight
of hand magic into low-budget camera
tricks but he was determined to achieve
Peter Parker spidey sense for real in
the film for a scene in which his newly
enhanced agility allows Peter to rescue
Mary Jane from a slip and catch her
entire airborne lunch neatly on a tray
no computer assistance was used Maguire
managed the trick himself with some
adhesive and props dropped strategically
from above of course that doesn't mean
it wasn't difficult the shot took 156
takes over a 16 hour shooting day true
abyss the true story of the RMS Titanic
is often seen as warning about mankind's
hubris the massive vessel was built to
break records and demonstrate English
superiority while catering to the
wealthiest people and it was woefully
unprepared for the disaster that ensued
when it struck an iceberg during
production James Cameron's 1997 film
Titanic seemed destined to fall victim
to ambition as well
Cameron intended to set an original love
story against the backdrop of a
painstaking recreation of the original
ship and it's sinking elaborate sets
difficult condition
and Cameron's exacting perfectionism
saddled the project with a constantly
bloating budget in a schedule that
spiraled out of control as it became the
most expensive movie ever made at the
time surprisingly while the intricate
ship sets and harrowing sinking scenes
provided Titanic's most dazzling moments
the most difficult seems to shoot
involve no effects or recreations at all
in fact it was Cameron himself who
embarked on a dozen expeditions to the
real shipwreck more than two miles below
the ocean's surface over the course of
two years to research material for the
film that was struck just by the the
surreal nature of the fact that I was
sitting here on this deck on these
lengthy and often dangerous dives
Cameron shot extensive footage of the
Titanic's present state for use in the
movies opening scenes the risks paid off
as the film became an unprecedented hit
hailed for its grandeur and spectacle
and earning more than its due at the box
office but it's hard to imagine anyone
else besides James Cameron who'd commit
to such an arduous undertaking just to
get a few authentic shots Spielberg's
sinking not only did Steven Spielberg's
jaws to find the modern summer
blockbuster it also demonstrated how to
create tension by withholding the reveal
of what the audience is afraid of this
wasn't entirely intentional as the
mechanical sharks frequent breakdowns
for Spielberg to show the beasts much
less than he originally planned the
young director was forced to develop
clever ways to suggest the man-eaters
presence without the use of the troubled
robot one of these quick fixes
ironically led to the most disastrous
day of an already beleaguered production
the heroic fisherman harpooned the shark
with the series of floating barrels that
signal its presence beneath the surface
for a scene in which the ominous
floaters circle the boat known as the
Orca the film's effects technicians
affixed a pulley system that controlled
their movement to the bottom of the hull
unfortunately the planks of the Orca
weren't strong enough to support this
rig and a quick yank on the barrels
ropes tore a hole in the boat's hull it
began to sink rapidly sending the crew
scrambling to rescue the cast equipment
and an entire day's footage from the sea
although this and several other
disasters push the shooting schedule
from the planned 55 days to a whopping
final tally of 159 days the Orca was
repaired the footage was saved and jaws
went on to reshape movie history
Disney's near-disaster Fantasia
the third animated feature from Walt
Disney Studios is a marvel on every
level particularly in the context of its
1940 production it may have been
underappreciated at the time but the
achievement of Fantasia's marriage of
technical innovation with artistic
ambition is hard to deny for the grand
finale of their concert feature Disney
and his artists envisioned a climactic
clash between the sacred and profane
pairing Modest Mussorgsky 'z Night on
Bald Mountain with Franz Schubert's Ave
Maria and it was quite an undertaking
the visuals for Ave Maria called for the
longest single shot in the history of
animation at the time as the camera
followed a procession through a densely
layered forest and into a Cathedral of
trees this meant that a lineup of
background paintings had to be set up in
to end across the length of a huge
soundstage the scene was completed once
only to have the horrified crew realized
they had put the wrong lens on the
camera a second attempt was foiled by an
earthquake all the while the scene was
frequently halted so that the soundstage
could be used for Walt's weekly
badminton game needless to say the final
shot took way longer than anyone
expected and in fact it was only
achieved in just enough time for the
film reels to be flown to New York mere
hours before Fantasia's premiere now
that's a close call